worked As a caretaker in the building
where she lived after a minor stroke she
said she was fired by the owner of that
building and along with her husband who
were forced out of their home and onto
the street
they came with police officers to my
door like we were criminals that wasn't
necessary they took my things dumped
them outside including my wedding photo
albums
a neighbor who owns a disused office
allowed the couple to stay there
the disrepair is obvious and there is no
running water and on their pensions they
cannot afford the now spiraling rents
it's a far cry from the real estate
fever that has gripped the city
Lisbon has become Prime Property for
wealthy foreign workers able to work
from home and the influx of these
so-called digital Nomads is being seen
as an opportunity to charge rents that
are beyond the salary of the average
Portuguese worker many overseas
professionals attracted to the idea of
living as digital Nomads in a city
famous for its beauty have been lured by
the Visa scheme for remote workers
the foreign demand for property goods
and services have driven up prices to
record highs and that's causing enormous
resentment in particular towards
property developers and landlords they
realize that they can rent and sell
their houses for much more money to
these digital Nomads so the Portuguese
actually don't count anymore in these
manipulated housing market that we live
in
even having a job is no guarantee of
avoiding poverty many of the people who
use this food bank are employed but
their wages are not enough to even feed
their own families
Lisbon city council hope that the
funding for the Pope's visit will create
more Investments for those who live here
we have now the biggest investment on on
housing on on public housing and try to
get solutions for the young people it's
it's of course it's a it's an enormous
question mark that we have in the future
and we have to deal with so Maria she
fears it will be too late for her and
her husband
what I fear now is that my next home
will likely be the cemetery
Sonia Gallego Al Jazeera Lisbon